[Music]
hello again I'm Dustin Kirkland and I'm
joined this time by Ian Lewis developer
advocate at Google he's going to tell us
a little bit about a new open source
container isolation sandbox called G
Weiser right so G Weiser is a sandbox
isolation project for containers it
provides a lightweight execution mode
for containers but also gives you very
secure isolation between those
containers really all about the security
isn't it exactly so for things like
containers they provide isolation in the
forms of in the form of namespaces and C
groups and as a feature of the Linux
kernel but you are exposed to kernel
bugs and things like that and unforeseen
issues which really are to the to the
Linux kernel and so if any sort of new
bug happens or that's the type of thing
you know a zero-day happens you are
exposed to that and so what this does is
it actually helps you to mitigate this
type of issue right it reduces the
surface as I understand it right right
so it actually provides a separate layer
okay in between the running application
and the the Linux chrome and what is
that layer so that layer is actually a
user space implementation or a user
space kernel okay so to be a little bit
detailed it's a influenced a lot of
Linux or most of the Linux Siskel's and
then provides user space virtualization
for the for the container cool and
you've got a demo for us here today tell
us a little bit about this demo and how
how it's gonna work
yes so this particular demo is going to
show a kernel vulnerability and what
we're going to do is we're gonna show
how that vulnerability can be used to
break out of the container and then out
of a normal container that's a Linux
container that's using namespaces and
how that can actually be mitigated when
using something you like or when using
gee visor okay and this is a real
vulnerability not something that you've
you've instrumented right this is a
vulnerability that has since been
patched obviously but it's one that if
it was released today sure would be a
would have been protected better by g5
yvg those are exactly interesting
so what we were going to do is we're
gonna take advantage of the dirty Cal
vulnerability in the Linux kernel I have
here is a OCI image or an OC I bundle
and in the configuration here we've got
a the UID and GID set to a user and here
we're going to run the a dirty cow
vulnerability and this is going to write
to a file that is controlled by root
from the user from within a container so
when they run this using run C this
takes a little while but the what's
happening here is that we are doing a
couple of Syst calls in parallel it's in
order to trigger a race condition in the
Linux kernel and that's going to allow
us to you write to a file that's
controlled by root and effectively gets
a privilege escalation okay so the the
exploit has run and so what we're gonna
do here is we're gonna check the the
file that we were going to write to so
here we were trying to write to the the
password file in this case our
particular export road to the exploit
Road to the beginning of the password
file so here you can imagine that you
could write in an entirely new line for
our road user and give it a new password
and essentially get privilege escalation
okay so what we're gonna do here is
we're going to run the exact same
vulnerability in the G Weiser sandbox so
here I have the exact same OCI bundle so
we'll look at the two config here we
have the exact same user user ID setup
UID and GID as well as the same exploits
that we're gonna try to run here and so
what we'll do is we'll use the run SC
command to invoke G visor and we will
run this with the P trace and s trace
commands and what this will do is allow
us to see these sis calls that are being
made by the exploit and here we can see
a lot of debug this particular exploit
is running the
is calling these sis calls in a loop in
a tight loop in two different threads
and so we can see those as there's a sis
calls being made here and intercepted by
G Weiser and because we have this extra
layer between the application and the
linux kernel here the G Weiser provides
we can intercept those and prevent the
vulnerability from actually happening so
now we've dropped out of that command
and we're gonna just take a look at our
password file to see if it was actually
been it's been written to so here we're
gonna we're gonna look at the contents
of the file and we can see here that the
the exploit was not actually able to
write to the file so that that's super
interesting actually if they if a user
is interested in downloading G Weiser
maybe running it today what what's the
minimum requirements how does someone
get started so right now we have it's a
normal open source project so we have
that it's released on github so you can
check that out and compile and run G
Weiser on your own it's it's very
similar in the end to to run C in the
sense that it provides two things and
provides a kind of a library that you
can use to run sandbox containers as
well as a command called run SC which is
very similar to run C in the sense that
it's a drop-in kind of replacement for
run C so you can use things like docker
to actually run a container okay great
and if someone wants to contribute to
this project it's an open source project
and as much as kubernetes is an open
source project sure absolutely so you
can contribute to the project by
engaging with us like through github and
submitting issues and and patches there
and joining kind of with in the kind of
community by providing feedback through
github that's great thanks
you